[Musica]
[Applauso]
ero di nuovo Fermo bloccato
smarrito il
problema era dentro di me o era intorno
a
me forse il problema era solo l'assenza
di movimento Il fatto stesso di essere
fermo da troppo tempo vedevo buio era
come avere un filtro scuro sulla realtà
nessun punto di
riferimento strano per uno come me dal
carattere entusiasta
iperattivo
ottimista i miei 40 anni erano lì ormai
alle porte 40 anni Mio papà 40 anni
stava per avere il quarto figlio le mie
due sorelle più piccole di
me già due figli a testa
Io tanti bei progetti qualcuno anche
realizzato con buoni riconoscimenti Ma
qual era il senso di tutti questi sforzi
da drogato di
lavoro la differenza la fa l'orizzonte
quando tu hai un orizzonte qualcosa in
cui credi una meta che desideri anche le
piccole difficoltà assumono un
significato ogni ostacolo ogni problema
fa parte del viaggio fa parte del
divertimento ma quando tu non sai dove
andare quando non sai se andare ogni
piccolo inconveniente genera angoscia
paralisi
e la paralisi è qualcosa che Erode il
tempo e limita lo spazio Vi è mai
capitato Magari è qualcosa che è
capitato a tutti A ognuno di noi magari
durante la pandemia L'angoscia la
paralisi sono come
un vortice come una spirale negativa Che
vi trascinano sul
fondo lo spazio si stringe si stringe si
stringe Allora come
ripartire Beh io una crisi Così ce
l'avevo già avuta magari più piccola era
stata all'altro giro di boa 10 anni
prima quando avevo avuto avevo compiuto
30 anni e lì come l'avevo
superata avevo deciso di fare il corso
da guida escursionistica e avevo
trasformato la mia grande passione per
il trekking per le montagne in qualcosa
di più in un'attività ed ero ripartito
con slancio ed entusiasmo avevo
conosciuto nuovi mondi avevo conosciuto
persone
meravigliose Ecco lo psicologo Morelli
in un suo bellissimo intervento
dice ci sono tanti altri mondi là fuori
Se vuoi stare bene devi andarle a
cercare se pensi solo al tuo piccolo
mondo ti ammali
ecco chi pensa solo al proprio piccolo
mondo finisce per ammalarsi se vuoi
stare bene devi cercare altri
mondi Allora devo trovare un altro mondo
devo cercare un
altrove dove sarà questa altrove non
vedo
indicazioni Allora forse semplicemente
devo provare a
partire vi riconosco voi scarpe Ma avete
spesso portato
lontano profumo di
libertà più o
meno già allacciarsi le scarpe è un
piccolo rito è un preludio di qualcosa
di bello di buono qualcosa di
nuovo decido che è ora da anni avevo in
mente un
percorso un viaggio fisico e anche un
po'
simbolico un tracciato che partisse dal
cuore della Metropoli di Milano a piedi
per piano piano ritrovare la natura
attraversando le valli selvage
dell'Appennino la nostra selva
oscura per poi arrivare fino al mare il
tuffo
nell'infinito Sì ma avrei retto un
percorso del genere cammini ne avevo già
fatti tanti ma avrei retto 10 giorni
solo con me
stesso avrei retto a tutti i miei
pensieri che affollavano la mia mente al
caldo di agosto agli ostacoli di un
tracciato mai percorso
prima spoiler sono sopravvissuto Ma
questo non lo potevo sapere all'inizio e
non lo sappiamo mai quando partiamo ma
solo l'idea di partire genera una
grandissima
opportunità ti fa intravedere un mondo
differente genera un varco nello
stallo già nel momento in cui ho pensato
di partire ho intravisto una via
d'uscita dalla
spirale Ma come si esce da una spirale
negativa discendente certo non conviene
risalirla prenderla di petto allora
magari è meglio fare un passo un passo
di lato un passo in
avanti un semplice difficilissimo
passo Ecco sono
fuori il primo passo è via sole in
fronte vento sulla pelle già mi rivedo
partire dal Duomo di Milano con uno Zino
enorme pieno di paure con la tenda il
saccap il materassino la maca da viaggio
cibo frutta secca cartine dei sentieri
unaa di cartografia ma soprattutto tante
insicurezze e intorno i milanesi che mi
guardano straniti questo sè perso
sicuramente io però non temo il loro
giudizio non li conosco sono
nell'altrove non ho paura dei loro
giudizi sono una persona nuova
qui parto saluto il duomo la madonina e
mi incammino attraverso la città
puntando verso sud le colonne di San
Lorenzo La Darsena e quindi inbocco il
Naviglio Pavese e già qui la prima
sorpresa quanta natura già qui in città
io aspettavo soltanto di vedere del
cemento dell'asfalto invece i parchi
urbani Gli argini del canale le chiuse
di Leonardo Da Vinci e poi la Certosa
Ecco Pavia cammino e cammino e piano
piano i miei pensieri si svolgono Si
allineano si fanno più
lucidi cammino e cammino e il mio corpo
torna in contatto con qualcosa di antico
di arcaico qualcosa che dentro di noi
l'uomo si è voluto con la sua postura
con la sua capacità di muoversi nello
spazio cammino e cammino attraverso il
parco del Ticino supero il grande fiume
il po ed è Ecco il mio corpo ora è in
grado di affrontare le prime salite
sulle colline
dell'oltrepò cammina ancora sempre più
forte e sempre più convinto Finalmente
sono in grado di affrontare le salite
vere quelle delle Valli profonde
dell'Appennino
la Val
Tidone attraverso il pontegobbo in Val
Trebbia a Bobbio la Cupa Valle tribolata
la bucolica Val D'Aveto ho più ricordi
di quei 10 giorni che di tutto l'anno
precedente bagni gelati nei torrenti
d'appennino frutti mangiati un po'
ovunque fragoli mirtilli
lamponi chiacchiere tantissime
chiacchiere con sconosciuti nei
paesini Ecco in quest' altrove il mio
spirito si espande in quest' altrove il
mio Io può finalmente
riconoscerci e anche il tempo mi sorride
si dilata il tempo è un tempo nuovo un
tempo diverso l'antropologa Maria
Molinari definisce questa cosa e dice in
un suo
saggio qui in Appennino lo spazio c'è ed
è amico del
tempo riparto e cammino e cammino a un
certo punto quasi inaspettato Ecco un
click cadono le
distrazioni cadono le paure il diaframma
si libera il il respiro si fa più
profondo la pelle freme i muscoli sono
più tonici Sono in uno stato di Grazia
sono altrove ma sono molto più Connesso
con me e con lo spazio intorno a me con
le persone col mondo di quanto mai sia
stato
prima
cammino ancora e finalmente lassù vedo
il il punto più alto del percorso
incomincio a
scrutarla quello è il montepenna è il
mio
Monte Io abito lì vicino da sempre a 11
anni I miei genitori mi Portarono in
campeggio lì e mi consegnarono al
parroco e io pensai Ecco sti fetenti mi
hanno
abbandonato dopo qualche tentativo di
fuga dopo due settimane non volevo più
tornare a casa un posto meraviglioso
dove ho stretto le prime amicizie dove
ho imparato a dormire nei
boschi il monte penna era la sede si
dice dello spirito pen lo spirito della
natura lo spirito dei boschi per gli
antichi celti
Liguri pare che anche il nome
dell'Appennino derivi da questo spirito
pen Ecco il monte penna è una
montagna magica a due versanti uno molto
scosceso la parete Nord aspro rocce
difficile scosceso e una morbida parete
sud che si percorre attraversando una
faggeta
accogliente io per forza dovevo fare la
via più difficile se volevo compiere
questo mio viaggio iniziatico e quindi
incomincio ad arrampicarmi era una
strada che avevo già fatto altre volte
non era la prima volta ma non l'avevo
mai fatta con uno zaino così pesante e
con 200 km nelle gambe salgo da solo mi
arrampico fra le rocce E ogni tanto mi
mangio anche qualche mirtillo per darmi
la carica salgo ancora E
finalmente sono in cima e sono ancora
solo mi guardo intorno laggiù la città
da cui son partito e poi le colline le
valli dell'Appennino
le vette silenziose e poi
laggiù c'è qualcosa che luccica che mi
sorride è il mare Quello è il mare che
mi aspetta Mi godo questo
momento sono attimi per cui vale la pena
vivere in cui ti senti
vivo poi apro gli occhi e vedo una folla
che arriva dalla parte della faggetta
dal sentiero semplice o almeno quello
che mi sembra una folla dopo 7 giorni da
solo sono i miei compaesani Cavoli è
verere feragosto e uele Ma dove vai con
quello zaino
gigante al mare e da dove arrivi da
Milano chiaramente credono che io sia
impazzito ma a me non importa ormai sono
consapevole di quello che sto facendo e
sono convinto della mia
meta sorrido parlo un po' con loro ma
devo ripartire il viaggio è ancora lungo
e voglio godermelo fino in fondo questo
viaggio con e dentro me stesso cammino e
cammino fino a
quando mi sorprende un compagno compagno
di viaggio a fianco a me è la mia ombra
ormai lunga nella luce del
tramonto Per un
attimo mi vedo da fuori mi guardo e
provo tenerezza per chi sono e orgoglio
per quello che sto
facendo tenerezza per chi sono e
orgoglio per quello che sto facendo io
che sono sempre stato così Severo con me
stesso decido di piantare la tenda di
godermi questo momento su un altopiano
della Val graveglia giusto in tempo per
l'ultimo raggio di sole laggiù fra le
onde del Mar Ligure la mattina dopo
riparto
all'alba scende al mare accompagnata dal
Lucchio delle onde e dai profumi della
macchia mediterranea e poi Eccola la Pia
del silenzio come una conchiglia
incastrata nella
costa accarezzo la
sabbia mi spoglio e il tuffo È
liberatorio il corpo nel pieno del suo
vigore viene accarezzato e cullato dalle
onde del mare è come un rito è come una
rinascita un po' come i cammini del come
i pellegrini del Cammino di Santiago che
una volta arrivati alla fine del mondo a
Finisterre in segno di rinascita
bruciavano i
vestiti forse anche perché fare il bagno
nell'Oceano Atlantico con le onde il
freddo che c'era non era il massimo ma
io invece me lo godo questo bagno me lo
sono
meritato sono pronto per tornare a casa
adesso Sono forte Sono sereno Sono
contento di quello che ho fatto e ho
dimostrato a me stesso che posso
raggiungere dei traguardi
e so Ormai Come alimentare questo
benessere so che questo altrove Potrò
ritrovarlo tutte le volte di cui ne avrò
bisogno Questo altrove sarà mio amico
sarà lì ad
aspettarmi La storia è finita Non ancora
Mi sono
perso sono partito mi sono
ritrovato la felicità è reale solo se
viene condivisa questa frase La
riconoscete è di tol ST
ma pare che forse sia più nota per il
film Into the wild Ecco io a differenza
del protagonista di Alex super Trump
sono tornato a casa non ho mangiato le
bacche sbagliate Ma una volta tornato a
casa ho voglia di condividere questa
bellezza questa bellezza come messi
insieme e quindi ne parlo i miei amici
riesco a coinvolgerli e quindi
Ripartiamo più volte e riusciamo a
segnare tutto questo percorso da Milano
all'appennino fino al mare
ecco quando siete tristi Quando siete
fermi quando Siete bloccati Provate a
partire provateci Eh ma tu non lo sai i
problemi che ho io io c'ho dell'altro
per la testa non ho
tempo per le cose importanti il tempo lo
si deve trovare sempre piuttosto andate
a lavorare a piedi prenotate un tracking
con degli sconosciuti oppure
semplicemente quando andate al parco
andate in una zona del parco dove non
siete mai stati in un piccolo altrove in
modo da avere altri
stimoli questo altrove vi sarà subito
amico in questo altrove vi ritroverete e
ricordate che l'altrove comincia sempre
con un semplice
passo
di